he's found his Lane now he knows if he
gets your back that's where he's special
and once a fighter knows that it's
trouble there was a while there where
you kind of could tell Sterling was
going to be something that he hit a
couple of roadblocks got that bad
knockout loss for example to Marlon
moration you know some stuff went
sideways not only has he found his own
identity but he simplified it if you
look at the effective takedown right now
Sterling it's very low it's in like a 40
percentage or something or even 20
percentage super low for a wrestler
that's really low that's his back
extremely low yeah but you might be
asking well how can it be so low and how
is this guy the champion the reason why
is because Sterling and some other guys
he's not alone in this regard but
there's a few guys right now who have to
this point done a really good job of not
looking for takedowns shooting takedowns
looking for back exposure yes sir that's
it they're just trying to get behind
your elbows and get your hands to the
mat that is it that's all they're trying
to do and then once they create back
exposure it's a it's curtains for you
bro curtains for you